[Musica]
questa storia la raccontava umberto eco
al suo amico moni ovadia la dico per
come la sua raccontare in una città
russa ebraica il loro rabbino e un
esimio cabalista un giorno questo
rabbino si vide arrivare uno dei suoi
con greganti jankel lo vede pallido
trafilato è anche la cosa ti succede
rabbino devo parlarti devo parlarti
siediti accomodati allora rabbino come
tutte le mattine stava facendo colazione
seta pane nero burro un'abbondante the
caldo zucchero bianchi sei scemo sei
venuto fin qui per raccontarmi della tua
colazione rabbino lasciami finire
allora stavo imboccando fetta di pane
stava pregustando la bontà della fetta
di pane quando a un certo punto è
saltato sul tavolo il gatto e mi ha
fatto cadere la fetta di pane a terra
rabbino dimmi da che parte è caduta la
fetta di pane a terra
jankel non scherzare e fisica è caduta
dalla parte del burro rabbino no ti
giuro ho testimoni è caduta dalla parte
senza burro a quel punto anche il
rabbino iii secolo diventa pallido e gli
dice questo è un fatto grave mistico vai
a casa che devo studiare
inizia lo studio
estrae tutti i contenuti dal libro dello
zohar della cabala scrive lettere ai più
grandi cabalisti sparsi in ogni parte
del mondo
smontano rimontano riniziano daccapo tre
anni di lavoro quando un giorno il
rabbino dice andate mia chiamare yankees
neanche da questa volta arriva
emozionato sudato e rabbino gli dice
bianchi siediti ce l'abbiamo fatta
tutto il mondo della cabala studiato per
33 anni per arrivare a dare una
spiegazione a quello che ti è successo
jankel a quello che ti è successo c'è
una e una sola spiegazione
ai imburrato fetta di pane dal lato
sbagliato
ora facciamo un gioco
divertiamoci lì ad immaginare
proiettiamoci nel futuro siamo nel 2030
e siamo il ceo di una multinazionale che
negli ultimi anni ha investito tutti i
capitali in tecnologia ha raggiunto
risultati straordinari ha raggiunto la
leadership del mercato
purtroppo però la tecnologia è diventata
una commodity a tutti gli effetti è
disponibile e accessibile a tutti in
qualsiasi momento
questo significa che abbiamo perso la
leadership del mercato significa che non
stiamo performando come prima significa
che non riusciamo ad attrarre talenti e
soprattutto stiamo perdendo le nostre
migliori risorse
questo è un fatto grave e mistico
non ce n'e capacitiamo incominciamo a
pensare ma come possibile qua ci viene
data una possibilità una e una sola
possibilità
quella di fare una domanda al computer
più potente che ci sia al mondo un
computer dotato di intelligenza
artificiale di machines di dat analytics
gli aiuti di cloud metaverso di tutto e
di più allora noi chiediamo a quest'ora
colo digitale di nome touring
come mai pur avendo investito tutti i
nostri capitali in tecnologia oggi non
siamo più i leader del nostro mercato
l'oracolo digitale dopo aver fatto tre
miliardi di ricerche analizzato 3
milioni di dati aver interrogato
altrettanti oracoli digitali sparsi in
ogni parte del mondo
dopo tre secondi ci risponde
a imburrato fetta di pane dal lato
sbagliato
ma che cosa significa questa risposta
non la capiamo non ha contestualizziamo
incominciamo a pensare torniamo indietro
con la mente agli anni della pandemia
dove forse tanti segnali anno sotto i
nostri occhi ma noi non riuscivamo a
leggere a carpire a capire interpretare
e quindi non ci diamo pace pensiamo
pensiamo a un certo punto abbiamo
illuminazioni il capitale umano
il capitale umano
in quegli anni di lloyd pubblico
l'undicesimo report intitolato global
human capital trench e diffondeva l'idea
che per un'azienda la differenza tra
sopravvivere e prosperare
dipende soltanto dal mettere al centro
di tutto l'essere umano
avevano capito che un mondo prevedibile
poteva essere approcciato con modelli
matematici algoritmi equazioni ma non il
nostro mondo nemmeno in un'epoca di
massimo sviluppo dell'intelligenza
artificiale
ora rimanendo nel 2030 e analizzando
quelle aziende che stanno performando
meglio di noi ci accorgiamo che quando
in tanti
stavano investendo tutto in tecnologia
queste aziende stavano investendo in
tecnologia in persone
avevano capito che il mondo con la
pandemia era cambiato non era più il
mondo di prima e dovevano creare valore
dei confronti di tutti
dipendenti clienti investitori
fornitori ambiente società territorio
comunità tutto e tutti sto valore veniva
creato riqualificando i dipendenti
promuovendo il loro benessere
garantendo la sovranità dei dati la
privacy dei clienti e soprattutto
progettando una tecnologia incentrata
sugli individui
avevano capito che la leadership stava
cambiando non ha leadership autoritaria
si stava passando sempre più a una
leadership condivisa
creativa e avevano capito che la
gentilezza
era l'ingrediente magico la chiave per
poter gestire tutte le differenti
generazioni
presenti nella stessa azienda per
finalmente la scienza era riuscita a
dimostrare attraverso una ricerca
condotta da harvard medical school e la
gentilezza produce felicità è un'altra
ricerca della pet o the public service
of canada aveva dimostrato che in un
ambiente rispettoso e gentile le persone
possiedono il 26 per cento di energia in
più
hanno il 30 per cento di probabilità in
più di sentirsi esposte a nuove idee
esprimono il 36 per cento
di soddisfazione in più per il proprio
lavoro e addirittura il 44 per cento di
impegni in più per le proprie
organizzazioni
ora tornando ad oggi
chiediamoci se fossimo il ceo di quella
multinazionale che nel 2030 perso la
leadership del proprio mercato dove
investiremo oggi in tecnologia o in
tecnologia in persone
il primo docente al mondo di economia
perché la prima cattedra al mondo di
economia sostituita in italia lui
antonio genovesi già nel
avere la risposta al nostro dilemma
ecco rispetto che riporto le sue parole
che da tanti anni ho fatto mi è
per il vostro interesse
nessun uomo potrebbe operare altrimenti
che per la propria felicità
sarebbe un uomo meno uomo ma se potete
quanto potete
studiatevi di far gli altri felici
perché legge nell'universo che non si
può fare la nostra felicità senza fare
quella degli altri
grazie
[Applauso]